le drame débute un samedi soir vers
23h30 les policiers en nouvelle écosse
met le public en garde contre une
personne armée en cavale dans la région
de portes à pic
un petit village côtier d'environ 100
résidents en bordure de la baie de fundy
la nuit passe dans la violence les
policiers continuent leurs recherches
mais en vain sinon ce matin ils
relancent leurs opérations avec plus
d'informations
l'homme recherché et gabriel whitman
hunt sur logist de 51 ans il est armé et
il est dangereux écrit la grc dans un
gazouillis si vous le voyez appelé le 9
1 1
à ce moment la police évoquait plusieurs
victimes sans en dire davantage
on était vraiment un cas connu haute
pour nos jours de même un corner des
membres de notre famille les membres de
la communauté certainement les pare
chocs avant des des hauts-fonds jeunes à
la maison de marie alouettes mènent
pourrait avoir été vêtu d'un uniforme de
policier même s'ils n'en étaient pas ont
ils auraient aussi pris la fuite dans
une voiture semblable à celle de la grc
en fait la seule différence qui
permettait d'identifier le véhicule du
suspect serait ce numéro à 5 caractères
inscrit à l'arrière côté passager au
milieu de la matinée la police annonce
que le suspect a changé de voiture et
qu'il conduit dorénavant un petit
véhicule utilitaire sport la chasse à
l'homme se termine finalement peu avant
midi à une station d'essence à une
demi-heure de route d'halifax pour cet
ancien policier qui a travaillé plus de
vingt ans dans les maritimes
l'opération a été malgré tout une
réussite
la réaction succès mais c'était assez
évident qu'un individu se diriger vers
un fax pour pouvoir justement à se
terrer en milieu urbain donc était
impératif pour les agents de la grc de
cesser cette cavale de plus rapidement
les premiers ministres maintenir des
trudeau n'ont pas manqué de réagir
il en profite
mes pensées accompagnent toutes les
personnes touchées par cet événement
je veux remercier les autorités pour
tout leur travail tout le monde pour
leur coopération des registres
progression indique que gabriel borkman
posséder plusieurs propriétés en
nouvelle écosse dont une clinique de
prothèses dentaires à dortmund ici
geneviève normes à radio canada moncton